FEMALE SPEAKER: Good afternoon,
everyone.
Authors at Google New
York is pleased to
welcome Andrew Blum.
[APPLAUSE]
ANDREW BLUM: Hi.
It's very, very exciting
to be here, for a
whole bunch of reasons.
The first and sort of most
obvious thing is we are
standing at the center
of the internet.
This building is the
mother lode, the
beast, in a lot of ways.
And for a whole bunch of
reasons, I've actually never
stepped foot inside of it.
Which is strange, because a
lot of the people I wrote
about spend many of their days
here-- separate from Google,
in the other parts
of the building.
The other reason it's
really fun to be
here is because when--
I guess it was in January when
my publicist at Echo first got
this book on her desk, the first
thing she said was, oh,
we should we pitch you to
Google to come talk.
And I said, have you read
pages 235 to 245?
And she said, no, not
yet, I'll read them.
Then she read them, she said,
OK, maybe that's not such a
great idea.
Because you guys are
my villain--
or, I should say,
were my villain.
Because after about six months
of going on and on about how
Google was the absolute
outlier in terms of
transparency of the sort of
classic [INAUDIBLE] that I was
looking at.
Suddenly last week, I woke up,
and got 15 emails from people
saying, oh my god, did you
see what story came out?
That Google has opened
the doors.
Glasnost.
I'm still getting over it.
I had to rearrange substantial
portions of my talk to
accommodate this new
transparency.
So it's all a bit of a
shock to me still.
How many of you, if
any, are in the
networking side of things?
None.
OK.
So you'll have no idea
if I'm right.
That's an amazing thing.
I'll talk a lot about this.
But one of the things that's
most surprising about this
topic is how small
a world it is.
At Microsoft, for example, there
are 90,000 employees.
You guys are how many now?
50, I think.
There are 200 people involved
with Microsoft Global Network.
There are, I think it was, four
involved with connecting
Microsoft's network
to other networks.
So you're talking about a tiny
fraction of people who are
involved with the things that
go on, astonishingly, inside
this building.
So that's getting ahead
of myself a lot.
What I want to start with--
sort of talk about different
pieces of the internet, and my
journey there.
But by way of preface, I came
into this, essentially, as an
architecture writer writing
about buildings.
And writing about buildings
comes with certain
assumptions.
And the most dominant assumption
is that if an
architect designs a building,
and it's shaped by this sort
of complicated mix of politics
and economics and real estate
and zoning and any number of
things, regardless of the
difficulty of understanding
those things, at the end of
the day, you can go and you
can walk around in it.
And you can see it.
And you can experience it.
And you can get some sense
of its sense of place.
You can kind of have a real
world experience of it.
But what was striking to me--
about four or five years ago,
2007, 2008, I was ostensibly
writing about architecture, but
I was not going out and
looking at buildings.
I was spending all my time
sitting at my desk
in front of a screen.
And then at the end of the day,
particularly starting
about 2007, I was then getting
up and looking at the smaller
screen that I was carrying
in my pocket.
And that was my new experience
of the world.
As I'm sure all of you do,
you're walking down the
street, and your attention's
divided between this physical
world around you and this
ostensibly virtual world
inside the screen.
And what was so striking to me
was that that world behind the
screen seemed to have no
physical reality of its own.
When you looked for images of
the internet, this was the one
that comes up again and
again and again--
this image by [? Opti ?]
of this amorphous blob that
you're not really meant to be
able to find yourself on it.
It kind of reminds me of the
Apollo blue marble picture of
the earth that I think is
similarly sort of meant to
suggest that we are to be awed
in the face of its expanse.
It's meant to make us
feel small, somehow.
And this was what the internet
looked like when this wasn't
really the actual
internet at all.
And that divide, that very stark
difference between the
world behind the screen and the
world all around me, the
world that I was supposedly
writing about and engaged with
professionally, became really
pronounced and amounted to a
kind of small scale existential
crisis.
How could I know myself if I
didn't know what this thing
was that I was attached to,
in the terms of the
world as I knew it?
And then one day,
this happened.
My internet broke, as it
occasionally does.
And the cable guy
came to fix it.
And he sort of followed this
clump of wires from behind my
couch out to the back of my
building in Brooklyn.
And then he saw a squirrel
running along the wire.
And he said, I think that's
your problem.
I think a squirrel is chewing
on your internet.
Which, of course, seemed
completely absurd, because the
internet is a transcendent
idea.
It causes revolutions and
changes shopping and dating,
and has changed the world
in so many ways.
It's not something squirrels
chew on.
But it turned out that it
absolutely was something that
a squirrel had chewed on.
And I got this image in
my head of yanking the
wire from the wall.
I should say, I talk about this
squirrel all the time.
And I haven't seen
him recently.
I'm getting a little
worried about him.
But this image of just yanking
the cable from the wall.
If you followed it,
where would it go?
I don't want to get to the end
of the story too quickly, but
it goes here.
It goes to this building.
And that became sort
of this question.
I started poking around.
How was it connected?
And the implication was that
oh, it travels by many
different paths, which seemed
to be the same as saying it
travels no paths at all.
But that couldn't be right.
That wasn't right at all.
But when I went to look for more
images of the internet, I
felt like a fool.
Because only fools
went to actually
look for the internet.
This is the episode of South
Park where the internet
breaks, but there's no internet
to know if the
internet's broken.
So they become refugees
in California.
It's very sort of
Grapes of Wrath.
And they finally find this thing
that is the internet.
And they play the Close
Encounters of the Third Kind
music at it to try
to wake it up.
And that doesn't work.
And then they shoot at it.
And finally, one of the little
guys goes around and unplugs
the plug and plugs it back in.
And the flashing yellow
light is steady green.
And it's salvation.
They're all saved.
Or if it's not a big box, it's
a little box, like in the
British sitcom The IT Crowd,
where they convince their
colleagues that they have
borrowed the internet for her
for the afternoon, so she
can present an office
presentation.
And she says, this
is the internet?
The whole internet?
Is it heavy?
And they say, of course
not, it's wireless.
Which is what most
of us think.
And that is the implication.
Or if it wasn't this sort of
sitcom version of what the
internet was, it was the poet's
version of what the
internet was and is.
And my favorite is a writer
named Christine Smallwood
here, who points out that the
"history of the internet is a
history of metaphors about the
internet, all stumbling around
this dilemma--
how do we talk to each other
about an invisible god?" And
then she weighs the merits of
describing the internet as a
Tootsie Roll, a hot tub,
a highway, a plane.
And then finally, she concludes
that she wishes that
the internet looked like Matt
Damon, or like lines of light
written by an invisible
hand in the night sky.
So we're back to the
amorphous blob.
There's sort of no escaping that
glowing amorphous blob.
But there was one guy who
had the internet number.
There was one guy who seemed
to have a sense of what the
internet actually was, which was
Senator Ted Stevens from
Alaska, who said in 2006, of
course, that the internet is
not a big truck.
It's not something you can
dump something on.
It's a series of tubes.
Which was hilarious.
It was absolutely not
a series of tubes.
It was, again, the transcendent
idea.
It was the cause of revolutions
and changes in the
economy and everything else.
But it's physical reality.
And yet it seems like what
else could it be?
I'm a little terrified by how
much time I've spent parsing
the dictionary definition
of tubes.
But again, if you load a single
web page, and then
there are 1,000 things happening
behind the scenes,
it doesn't negate the fact that
each one of those things
is passing through, has a
distinct physical path, is
coming to you through any number
of places, but through
absolutely real places.
Places, occasionally, like
this, which is in Kansas.
On the left is a fiber optic
regeneration hut.
And this came out of the piece
that sort of started me on
this topic for Wired, three
and a half years ago now,
where we set out to get a
collection of images of the
internet, the physical
internet.
And one of the questions was is
there a place in the middle
of the country that regenerates
the fiber optic signals?
And I tried to find out, and
it turned out there was.
And I was talking to a press
person at what was then Global
Crossing, owner of a big piece
of internet backbone, and
said, is there a box in the
middle of the country?
And she got on the phone a guy
with a pickup truck in Kansas
City who is responsible for
all of the fiber optic
regeneration huts in
a 500 mile radius.
And we then proceeded to have
this very strange conversation
about which was the most
beautiful of these huts.
And it turned out
to be this one.
But it's quite clear that this
is what is out there.
If the basic unit today, not
connected to your home, but
for the backbones, for the
center, for the largest
networks, is a 10 gigabit per
second wave of light, pulses
of light, sort of nanosecond
Morse code through, most
often, a yellow fiberoptic
jumper cable--
that's the kind of basic
unit of connection.
If the internet is a network
of networks, then it's all
about the space between
two networks.
No network is--
actually, there might be one
network that is less of an
islet than others-- but
for the most part, no
network is an island.
It has to connect to others.
And it does so through yellow
fiber optic jumper cables like
this, where if you bend
them, light comes out.
It's that tangible.
And to kind of begin to talk
about it in those terms,
though, requires something
of a caveat.
If logically what goes on when
you load a single web page or
do anything else is incredibly
complicated, it is very
difficult for almost all of us
to access is the kind of world
of algorithms and bits.
Physically what it is, and
geographically where it is,
are realms that are much
more accessible to us.
This is the world we learn
to navigate as children.
This is our sort of embodied
experience of the world.
And so for me, it was a question
of putting aside the
logical, at least
temporarily--
you have to understand it
to a certain extent--
and saying, what is this
and where is it?
What is it made of?
And where is it?
And it ends up being a lot of
yellow fiber optic cables like
this that then sort of gather
together in these increasingly
thick bundles.
So the basic unit is a network,
an autonomous system
in technical terms.
Is that a word that any
of you engage with?
Occasionally?
OK.
So if Google is a network, and
Facebook's a network, and
Goldman Sachs is a network, and
Cablevision is a network,
and Comcast's a network, they
physically connect to each
other, the router of one network
to the router of
another network.
A big, refrigerator size machine
with blinking lights
connected, often with a yellow
fiber optic cable like this,
to the router of the
other network.
And again, it's difficult to
overstate this, but quite
remarkably, they connect
in this building.
There are about a dozen
buildings in the world that
are by far the most important
places where the networks of
the internet connect.
This is one of them.
And it's very exciting
to say that.
In those buildings, in these
buildings, there are usually
anywhere around 400 or 500
networks interconnecting.
In the next tier of places where
networks meet, there are
usually an order of
magnitude less.
There are usually more like 40
or 50 networks interconnecting
in these enormous jumbles
of yellow cables.
And what's striking to me is
if it's always about this
physical connection.
Not a single unique
connection.
It's not as if Google and
Comcast connect their routers
in one place.
They connect them in multiple
places, but not as many as you
might expect.
These connections of one machine
to another, this sort
of inter internet, then kind of
pile up and come to sort of
this building scale collection
of interconnections in places
like 60 Hudson Street in
Tribeca, which is another one
of these dozen buildings in the
world where more networks
of the internet connect
than anywhere else.
Particularly remarkable because
it's the place where
most of the transatlantic
cables--
depending on how you count,
there are 8 or 10 or 12 of
them across the Atlantic--
and the majority of them
interconnect with everyone
else on the ninth floor
of 60 Hudson Street.
And it's a fascinating history
in its own right.
It was the Western
Union building.
It was the telegraph
interconnection, and then,
through post breakup of the
Bells, became the place where
the independent, the autonomous
networks of the
internet connected
with each other.
This, again, is another
building.
This is another one of them.
Bought two years ago.
It was the largest single
real estate
transaction of the year.
As I understand, it was the
largest single line item in
the SEC filings.
And it was remarkable for those
of us who were looking
closely at the connections
among internet networks,
because it totally went under
the radar screen.
The importance of this
building as a network
crossroads went entirely
unremarked upon, to the point
where the Wall Street Journal,
in its account of the largest
single real estate transaction
of a single building in 2010
said, oh, one third
of the space is
telecommunications companies.
When the announcement was
they're expanding rapidly, we
need the office space.
Clearly, there's compression
here.
I know about the move
across the street.
But I sort of laughed,
because this is it.
This is one of the most
important places.
These buildings are sort of
founded on the basic principle
that the owner of the
building is neutral.
It's a carrier neutral
building.
The owner of the building does
not interfere with the
connections going on.
That's a kind of basic principle
of the autonomy of
these connections.
So I was sort of like, well,
this is surprising.
And I realized it was kind of
like American Airlines buying
LaGuardia Airport and saying, we
really just a place to park
our trucks.
It didn't seem to reflect the
importance of this as a hub.
And that story is still
evolving, actually.
And there was later slightly
more comment about the
relationship of Google's
ownership of this building
with the treatment of the
existing telecommunications
companies that interconnect
here.
But again, if you see parked on
16th Street a white truck
with a lightning bolt, that is
because in many, many parts of
this building--
one third of it, probably
a little bit less now--
are these really dominant
interconnections between networks.
Actually, this is where my
internet comes from.
I live in Brooklyn.
And I'm a Cablevision
customer.
My signal goes back to
Cablevision's back office in
Long Island--
I forget which town, I'm
blanking on the name--
and then comes back to 111 8th,
where it interconnects
with the rest of the internet.
And that's a key idea.
But the other piece that
I love is the kind of
geographic, is this idea that
if there are this relatively
short list of buildings where
more networks connect than any
other, those buildings are then
in very specific places.
And they are quite literally
connected to the Earth.
So when you walk into
a data center--
and I use that term kind of
loosely, not as a place where
data is stored, but as just a
room filled with computing
equipment--
they're loud and cold.
They have a very particular
smell.
The internet always smells kind
of like burnt toast, kind
of like new car smell.
Has anyone been in those
spaces here?
With that kind of ozoney smell,
if you walk by doors
where there's like-- yeah?
So it's a sort of dominant
sensation of it being so loud
you can hardly hear yourself
and 65 degrees.
When you walk into this room,
which is the fiber vault in
another one of these most
important buildings--
this one in Virginia--
it's hot, and it's still,
and it smells like dirt.
Because this is where the fiber
comes out of the ground.
This is the kind of connection
between the network, between
what ostensibly is this
amorphous blob, and the
Virginia clay.
And that's quite distinct.
And I love those moments where
that scene between physical
and virtual is most explicit.
And it's often in
rooms like this.
That building in Virginia,
again, another one of the list
of buildings, another one
of those list of a dozen
buildings in the world, run by
a company called Equinix
that's very much a competitor
to Telex.
Equinix actually has space
in this building--
has quite a bit of space in
this building, I think.
But their most important hub
is near Dulles Airport in
Virginia, in Ashburn,
Virginia--
Ashburn being a place that
internet networking people,
internet workers, talk about
as if it were London or
Frankfurt, and usually
in the same sentence.
So if you say, where are
the most important
places of the internet?
They say New York, Frankfurt,
Tokyo, Ashburn, as if Ashburn
were a global capital--
which for the internet,
it absolutely is.
And you kind of get a sense from
this picture of how that
plays out on a kind
of building scale.
You have this complex of
buildings in the middle.
There's five buildings there
that make up the Equinix
Ashburn campus that are mostly
distribution depots.
These are the places that are
all about interconnection.
This is kind of the primest real
estate on the internet--
the most expensive real
estate on the
internet, you might say.
And around it are these
warehouses, or these kind of
beached aircraft carriers, that
are more the warehouses
to the distribution depots.
That combination
is quite clear.
They're kind of tethered
into these buildings.
And if the security of this
makes you nervous--
which would be surprising.
Because if it made you nervous,
then you would also
be sort of working at this
enormous bull's eye as well.
So I guess your relationship to
that might be slightly more
complicated than most people.
But when a piece of tubes was
excerpted with a piece about
Equinix Ashburn, we put an
admittedly sensational
headline of the bullseye
of America's internet.
And then put red circles
around it.
And then all that week, Equinix
tweeted, we are the
bull's eye of America's
internet.
We are the bull's eye of
America's internet.
Because the importance to
announce the importance of
this place as one of the major
points of interconnection is
absolutely crucial.
That is what their
business it.
It's also striking, if there's
a relatively short list of
buildings, it's a very
small social group.
Usually about 200 or 300 people
gather together three
times a year under the banner
of NANOG, the North American
Network Operators Group,
actually meeting
right now in Dallas.
And these are the people who are
responsible for connecting
their network to
other networks.
And they will run the big global
network of a Google--
Google's got five or six people
are usually there, of
about 300--
and then negotiate these
connections called peers,
which usually is a very
personal process.
It depends a lot on trusting
the person and the network
you're connecting to.
So they drink a lot of beer.
They decide if you're
clueful, which is
the opposite of clueless.
And then if you are,
then you agree to
connect your networks.
And then you consummate that
connection with a yellow fiber
optic cable in a building like
Equinix Ashford or 60 Hudson
Street or here.
And so you hear these
conversations like, OK, where
should we connect?
And it's like, Dallas,
111, 60, Ashburn.
And that's the list.
And there can be a lot of tricky
politicking and very
difficult to parse economic
agreements, financial
agreements, in those connections
between networks.
But at the end of the day,
the coordinators--
those can be the peering
coordinators, peering being
this work for connecting to
networks as if they were
peers, or paid peers, meaning
you pay them as well for the
privilege of connecting--
that relationship is incredibly
intimate, and is
incredibly small.
Incredibly small group
of people.
If the sort of most important
center of the internet are
these very small list of places
where the networks of
the internet predominantly
connect with each other, the
next piece-- in some ways,
the more poetic piece--
are the lines in between,
specifically the undersea
cables that connect
continents.
This is another image from
that Wired photo essay.
Again, came out of this surreal
conversation saying,
OK, is there a manhole where
the undersea cable
connects to the beach?
And the answer is yes.
OK, which is the most
beautiful manhole?
It turned out to be this one,
near Halifax in Nova Scotia, a
cable that connects Nova
Scotia with Ireland.
The only cable, actually,
transatlantic that isn't from
the New Jersey or Long Island
beaches to the UK, to England,
but rather takes a more
northerly route, for specific
reasons of security through
diversity by being in a
different place.
The cables--
it's difficult to overstate how
wondrous they are, in that
they're the thickness of a
garden hose in one direction.
In the other direction, they are
4,000 of 5,000 or 6,000 or
8,000 miles.
Usually, there's a kind of
steel mesh outside for
structure, and then usually,
a copper tube--
I use that word technically--
that transmits the electricity
that powers these repeaters
that sit on the ocean floor,
that are these kind of big
tuna shaped things every
50 miles or so
that amplify the signal.
And then in the sort of heart of
it are usually four or six
or eight strands of fiber,
hair thin strands.
And if the basic yield is a 10
gigabit per second wave,
what's amazing is that each
strand of fiber can carry not
just one wave, but many
different wavelengths or
colors of light through
that strand of fiber.
So 50 or 60 or 75 10 gigabit
per second waves of light
through each fiber, perhaps four
going in each direction.
So that's a lot of information
that is through a space that's
difficult to comprehend
in one dimension.
You look out across the ocean,
and it is that kind of
ultimate expanse of the other.
So I really wanted to see one
of these cables being built.
If our life online is kind of
defined by these fleeting
moments of connection, of some
random email or Facebook post
or tweet or whatever it is,
then it seemed like there
could be a physical corollary
to that, a moment when a
continent was plugged in.
This is Simon Cooper.
We've never actually met.
We've only talked on his
telepresence system.
He works for Tata
Communications, which is the
communications wing of Tata,
the big Indian industrial
conglomerate.
He's an Englishman.
He works in Singapore.
The undersea cable industry
is entirely dominated by
Englishmen.
They all seem to be 42, because
they all started
basically at the same time,
about 20 years ago.
And Tata had bought out
of bankruptcy a big,
metaphorically speaking, cable
across the Pacific and a big
cable across the Atlantic, and
then proceeded to finish the
loop around the world with the
idea that they would promise
to send your bits
east or west.
And if something happened to
the cable in the Pacific--
which has, in fact, happened--
they would send your data
around the other way.
And if a cable does break or is
damaged somehow, of course
you have to send a ship out,
throw a grapple hook over the
side, pick it up, find the other
end, fuse each strand of
fiber together, and then throw
it back into the water.
So it's this incredibly
physical,
incredibly handmade process.
Actually, quite a bit of
Google's global network runs
on Tata's undersea cables.
I'm breaking all sorts of
confidentiality agreements by
saying this.
It's actually not in the book.
But when you go to a Tata
landing station-- and I didn't
even see it, I could barely make
it out-- but I think when
you go to a Tata landing
station, there's a whole bank
of yellow cables that
are labeled--
I couldn't quite figure out how
to spell it, but I think
it started with a G--
that are Google's wavelengths.
These are the wavelengths
across the ocean.
Of course, based on this kind
of basic gamble that the
larger your network
gets, the more you
want to run it yourself.
The more you don't just want to
buy a circuit, but you want
to run the wavelength.
You want to perhaps even own
the fiber, perhaps even own
the conduit through which
the fiber runs.
That's what's meant
by the dark fiber.
And that becomes quite tangible
when you visit these
places, because inevitably,
you get to the spot in the
tour of these buildings
where there's the
bank of Google's fiber.
Which, again, these visits are
based on the premise that
you're not going to remark upon
who is in which place,
except in so much as often, a
company's presence in these
locations is announced.
Because if they're there, they
want to interconnect.
And so there are open websites
that say where everybody is,
because you can't be silent.
You have to interconnect.
Otherwise, what's the point
of being there?
Anyway, so Tata was building
a new cable.
And he said, we'd be happy
to tell you when that was
happening so you could watch
this cable be connected.
And he gave me about
four days' notice.
He said if you show up at this
beach just south of Lisbon at
a little after 9:00 on Monday
morning, this guy will walk
out of the water.
Which is what happened.
This was the first link for his
first connection from sea
to land carrying a lightweight
nylon messenger line, just a
basic line.
The first link that would then
be leveraged into what was
called the WACS cable-- the
West Africa Cable System--
from Lisbon down the west
coast of Africa, to Cote
d'Ivoire, to Ghana,
all the way to
Namibia and South Africa.
The construction of which began
with, again, this guy
coming out of the water.
And then a sophisticated ship
sort of steamed around.
And a skiff brought the
cable out to the ship.
And then they began to pull
it in using the bulldozer.
You can see the English
engineers looking on, the
Spanish underwater construction
team doing some
of the heavy lifting, the local
day laborers doing some
of the even heavier lifting.
And then once it's in place,
that same guy goes back in the
water with a big knife, and
he cuts each buoy off.
The buoy pops up in the air.
And the cable drops to
the ocean floor.
And then he does the
whole thing all the
way out to the ship.
And then when he gets there,
they give him a glass of juice
and a cookie.
And he jumps back
in the water.
And he swims the kilometer
back to shore.
And then he gets out and
lights a cigarette.
And then that connection's
made.
And then they start preparing
to attach the cable to the
other side that's been brought
down from what's known as the
landing station, which is
basically the lighthouse, the
place that sends and receives
the pulses of
light through the fiber.
And in order to get through
the steel armor and get
through the copper tube that
conducts electricity and get
to the fibers to manually fuse
each of the eight of them to
the one that's been brought down
from the landing station,
you need to go at it
with a hacksaw.
And so when you're standing
there and you're watching them
work at this cable with a
hacksaw, the amorphous blob
seems a really long way away.
It starts to seem like a lot
more tangible thing.
Then when the tide goes out,
they cover it, just the first
little bit out to sea, to
protect it from anchors and
stuff like that.
And they try to do as much of
that as possible without
having to get their
scuba gear on.
And what's remarkable is that
if the material science is
incredibly sophisticated, and
the computational technology's
incredibly sophisticated--
again, 10 gigabit per second
pulses of light times
70 times 4--
the basic physical connection
is the same
as it's always been.
And the places that are
connected are the same.
Often port cities--
New York or Lisbon or
Mombasa or Mumbai or
Singapore or Hong Kong.
And the culture is the same.
The same English engineers-- you
can see the guy in the hat
looking on.
The same local laborers.
And that physical process
of connection persists.
It's about three, four days on
the beach of construction.
And then when it's done, they
put the manhole cover back on,
and they push the
sand over it.
And then everybody in this
village and all of us kind of
forget about it.
And that seems a shame.
The basic premise of the cloud
is that when you put something
on the cloud, you give up some
responsibility for it.
You often lose quite a bit of
knowledge about where it is or
what it is or how it's
being handled.
And I think we shouldn't
forget that.
We should keep in mind that it's
made of places like this.
So this is in the
woods in Oregon.
If one of the major components,
the physical
infrastructure of the internet,
are the internet
exchange points, the places
where the networks
interconnect, and another is
the lines in between, these
cables that connect places
across distance, then the
third, undoubtedly, are data
centers, are places
where data is stored.
And what's remarkable is that
the number one and number two
most visited website--
Facebook and Google, Google
and Facebook--
made the same decision about
five years apart, which was to
locate their first ground up
data center in essentially the
same place in central Oregon.
For all sorts of reasons.
For certainly the availability
of power.
The coolness of the air-- so you
can save as much money as
possible cooling data centers
by just literally but
basically opening the windows.
The availability of the fiber
optic connections, the
robustness of those fiber optic
connections, and the tax
breaks that sort of make
the towns in which
they're in good hosts.
But it was striking that to make
that same decision five
years apart in the same place is
indicative of the power of
these forces are that allow
buildings that could be
anywhere to be in very
specific places.
So this is the woods behind
Facebook's data center in
Prineville, Oregon, and hemmed
in by these huge power lines.
And before I went, my image of
these places was as sort of
belching information
age factories.
That's how they've often
been portrayed.
When I got there, it
was very different.
Facebook--
let's talk about Facebook
first--
in Prineville had really been
embraced by the community with
open arms, and Facebook had
embraced Prineville.
And it quite directly took the
place of industry that had
left with the economic collapse
of central Oregon
otherwise, and quite precisely
took those same power
connections--
not in this case, but actually
in Google's case with the
closed aluminum smelter.
So for those reasons,
was quite welcome.
A lot of you probably saw that
the New York Times series a
few weeks ago about data
centers, which for me and a
lot of people in the industry
didn't seem very strange.
Certainly there are data centers
using an enormous
amount of power, but in fact
much less than we might
expect, particularly in
proportion with the benefit
they provide.
And the have mantra in the
industry is always to use as
little power as possible.
So that series that sort of
announced the waste of power
seems sort of strange,
particularly picking on the
most sophisticated players
in the industry--
in the Times', case,
Microsoft.
But what was remarkable to me,
though, about Facebook, about
Prineville, was the degree to
which they were eager to
monumentalize this building, the
degree to which this was a
place that they sort of
celebrated as a temple of
Facebook's data.
As a writer about architecture,
it's basic idea,
a basic tenet, that buildings
express ideas.
And it was quite special for me
to see the degree to which
Facebook was celebrating
this data center.
Of course, the guys who run the
building complain about
all the silly things
the architects did.
But what came out, I think,
is quite beautiful, and is
remarkable for the way that
rather than looking like the
back of a parking lot, of a
shopping mall loading dock, as
most of these buildings often
do, there was some attempt to
say this is a special place.
And that continues
inside as well.
And even more so, the doors
were thrown wide open.
There was a sense that this
is your place as well.
There's a joke, obviously,
to be made about
Facebook and privacy.
But beginning about a year ago,
Facebook has made the
decision to publish the plans
of this data center at Open
Compute Project-- to say that
this is the most efficient we
can build this building, and
the best thing for the
industry is to share the things
that we've learned, and
open up the building, and
publish everything down to the
circuit board, and say if we all
are going to improve, and
the best thing we can be doing
to lessen our impact is to
share best practices.
And that kind of sense of
integrity is sort of permeated
throughout the building.
That said, being
in this place--
this is ostensibly the place
where things of emotional
resonance come from.
This is where the announcements
of new babies,
new jobs, and whatever
it is, are stored.
And that final leap for me--
sort of saying I know this
stuff is here, but what
does that mean--
that final connection was
difficult to make.
It was hard to finally connect
this sort of virtual world
that I was in the presence
of with what I
knew it meant to me.
So all of that is made much
more complicated for me in
front of you this week.
If this were three weeks ago,
it would have been a
completely different story.
But essentially, the way that I
have been telling the story
is that where Facebook was wide
open and eager to share
best practices, Google was
completely closed.
And for me, it was quite
striking to my visit to the
Dalles, which I did go see.
And by go see, I was given a
tour of the parking lot, and
then given this delicious
lunch.
But it was quite striking how
different the desire to share
and for me, the degree to which
Google was the outlier.
In terms of willingness to allow
me to understand, and by
extension readers and some of
you to understand, what goes
on inside these buildings, was
very different in tone
compared to everybody
else that I saw--
all the dozens of places
that I visited.
I'll be specific about
that in some ways.
This is the Google Maps image
of the Dalles circa 2010.
It is not an old image.
It is an obscured image.
As a Google Maps user, the idea
that a Google data center
wouldn't be just absent or old
but would be actually obscured
was, for lack of a better
word, a kind of
violation of trust.
The assumption is that this is
an accounting of the world
that is as honest as
possible at points.
The deliberateness of that
obfuscation was quite dramatic.
Quite dramatic as well for--
again, I won't repeat back
your mission statement,
but it's quite clear.
When we give things to
the cloud, we give up
responsibility for them.
The message that I got in dozens
of places was that
you're right.
This is something we should
be talking about.
This is something that
we should know about.
You can read the gory details,
but my visit to the Dalles
sort of played out like farce,
and a complete disconnect of
what I was asking for and
completely different than what
had been explained to me in
dozens of other places.
And last week, this amazing
set of images, and this
amazing push to communicate what
these buildings were made
of came out--
the piece written by Steve
Levy at Wired.
And we had a nice exchange
last week.
I was very glad that he was the
one that came over, that
he was the one that wrote the
story about Google's data
centers at long last.
And again, it's difficult to
communicate how significant it
was for me to talk about this
for so long as saying that we
should know what our virtual
world is made of, and with the
elephant in the room being
completely shut down, absolute
just zero transparency
whatsoever--
and then suddenly, the
doors have opened.
And that's a kind of remarkable
thing, to which it
has lots and lots of
exciting effects.
This was last week.
I was like, OK, great,
thank you.
I'm sure Ted would be pleased.
Down the road from the Dalles
is the Bonneville Dam.
And is this great WPA or Army
Corps of Engineers project.
It's a fortress.
When you go and you visit it,
an armed guard checks your
trunk and then says,
come on in.
And then when you go inside,
there's a visitor center, and
a gift shop, and displays about
the very complicated
environmental and economic
history of this place.
And there's this sense that this
is your infrastructure.
And for me, that's obviously
in stark contrast with the
places that are completely
shut down, that we know
nothing about.
But also a model for the way in
which we can be connected
to our digital infrastructure.
So this is my image of it.
My dream of it is, quite
literally, a brewery tour--
not of this building as a whole,
but a brewery tour of
the place where Google connects
to the rest of the
internet, with a glass wall and
blinky lights and red hats
or whatever it is.
But it seems like there is
a way that we should be
celebrating this infrastructure
in more
deliberate ways.
Thank you.
Thank you for indulging my
uncomfortable feelings about
all of you.
[APPLAUSE]
FEMALE SPEAKER: Can you
take questions?
ANDREW BLUM: Yeah, sure.
AUDIENCE: The Wired photo that
you referred to-- is that the
Neal Stephenson "Mother Earth
Mother Board" article?
ANDREW BLUM: No, it
was a new one.
It was one that I
put together.
2009, a photographer named
Randall Mesdon, famous for the
Marky Mark underwear pictures
as well as his
pictures of the internet.
AUDIENCE: Is there a place
we can go to see them?
ANDREW BLUM: Yeah.
The piece is called
"Netscapes." Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Great book.
I loved it.
ANDREW BLUM: Even pages
235 to 245?
AUDIENCE: At that point, I
worked for a large bookseller
that has [INAUDIBLE].
So there was an apocryphal story
I heard a lot in the
early '90s from [? nano ?]
geeks.
And I'm hoping you can
tell me if someone--
Jay Adelson or someone--
mentioned it or you did
research and debunked, because
I've always wondered.
But in the early days of
MAE-East when the gigaswitch
first happened, and the idea of
IX was so new, there was a
story told about how the
cleaning ladies would
turn off the power.
The gigaswitch originally
digital, sort of stuck it in a
corner, and there was a bunch
of surge protectors to it.
And there was a story told
around that time-- '92, '93--
that every so often, they'd
just pop the fuse and
it would turn down.
And of course, [INAUDIBLE]
resilient to it.
Did you hear that story?
It wasn't in the book.
ANDREW BLUM: I heard that
story in every place I
visited, yeah.
AUDIENCE: Did you debunk it?
ANDREW BLUM: It happened.
I mean, when things go wrong,
they go wrong in such silly
ways that if not has happened
in those exact terms, it
happened that way
all the time.
One reason that there isn't
huge concerns about the
location of the cables, about
the maps of the buried fiber
optic cables or anything like
that, is that the by far
greater concern on everyone's
part is some guy with a
backhoe, not terrorists.
The great story from the last
year and a half is a woman in
Armenia who was digging for
copper in her backyard who cut
through with a spade Georgia's
connection to the internet.
There was a story, which
apparently is not true, but of
some of the outages for Google's
data center in the
Pacific Northwest being caused
by hunters shooting the fiber
optic lines that are strung on
top of the Bonneville Power
Association regional grid.
That, apparently,
was not true.
That was kind of a joke said.
That I did debunk.
But there's so many stories
about silly missed
connections.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
My name's Matt.
I don't know how many months
ago I emailed you.
ANDREW BLUM: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: But thank you for
coming, and despite
pages 235 to 245.
In your book, you give
kind of two extremes.
ANDREW BLUM: Thank you
for having me,
despite those pages.
AUDIENCE: In your book, you give
kind of two extremes of
the government's involvement
in these kind
of bull's eye sites.
You have the town administrator
in Oregon shows
you his connection to the
internet, and that's kind of
like the bake sale supplies
in the basement.
And then you have the dockyards
in London, with the
2007 terrorist plot that's
broken up by Scotland Yard.
In your writing this book, and
investigating this for the
past few years, did you ever get
into the question or try
to ask the question about what's
being done to protect
these sites outside of
just not putting a
sign on the wall outside?
ANDREW BLUM: Yeah.
The first thing to say is the
security concern about the
lines in between are backhoes
and ships' anchors.
The security concerns at places
like Ashburn or in this
building are often about, well,
first, somebody walking
out with a pizza box size
thing worth $40,000 or
$150,000, much less the credit
card data that it holds.
So the security concerns are
often based on not terrorist
malfeasance, but on theft
of different kinds.
A lot of these major hubs--
60 Hudson Street, in the
immediate aftermath post 9/11,
was surrounded by dump trucks.
There was really great awareness
of this as a
strategic place.
Places like Equinix Ashburn have
followed, are required to
follow, all sorts of different
levels of both government
security standards and often,
it's the bank audits, the
financial institution audits,
that you must be in a class
whatever data center, which
means there has to be a camera
every six feet, and three
layers of doors with
this kind of locks.
That's what the security's
about, not as much about a
terrorist threat of any sort.
And then there's the flip side
of it, which is that for these
dominant interconnection points,
you can't hide them.
They rely for their success
on everybody
knowing where they are.
And that's a kind of crucial--
when the al-Qaeda plot to blow
up Telehouse, the 60 Hudson or
111 8th equivalent in London,
was foiled, the Telehouse
people said, why, yes, actually,
we are the most
important spot on
the internet.
It would make perfect
sense to blow us up.
Because that's the position
they want to maintain.
So that sort of trumps
all other concerns.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: You've got all these
pictures of jumper cables.
I worked a long time
ago on stuff for
doing this free space.
Is any of that stuff happening
in free space
now, or did that die?
ANDREW BLUM: The efficiency of
the cables is so clear that
any implication of it evolving
out of that--
there are these news articles
about things
replacing them, but not--
it seems that it's--
Well, that said, the 10 gigabit
per second wave has
become over the last few years
occasionally a 40 gigabit per
second wave or a 100 gig wave.
Same strand of fiber switching
the flashlights on either end.
Also, that was like with Egypt,
it was like, oh, the
government's going to put a
Wi-Fi blimp over Cairo, and
provide internet access separate
from government
shutting it down.
And that just seems impossible
to believe.
When my phone works in Times
Square, then we can think
about blimps providing internet
access to all of the
city through some secret
government
technology or anything.
AUDIENCE: About six years ago,
someone told me that there's
an internet exchange in Palo
Alto which something like 20%
of all the traffic
goes through.
Is that realistic, and
has that changed?
Did you recover information
about that instance?
ANDREW BLUM: Yeah.
The building in Palo Alto is
known as the PAIX, the Palo
Alto Internet Exchange.
It is another one of
these 12 buildings.
I spent a lot of time there.
One of the chapters is built
around a visit to to that
building as well as Ashburn,
which were both--
the issue's a little bit
complicated, but basically
both the invention of Jay
Adelson, a guy who has since
gone to do other things less
physical with the internet.
And the 20% number--
because the traffic is so often
within a single network,
and because a single yellow
piece of cable might have one
10 gigabit strand or it might
have nothing or it might have
40, any measurements that are
done are done through some
sort of sampling process.
I focus on physical terms,
obviously, and I focus on this
list of, which I always say,
about a dozen buildings.
And I've gone through the list
with some of my favorite
network engineers, and
it usually is pretty
clear that there are.
But it's more about not
quantities of traffic, but
number of networks
interconnecting.
So Google and Comcast,
for example.
There, it's like, OK, we're
going to connect.
We're going to do a pair.
We're going to connect in
New York and in Ashburn.
So we'll connect at 111
and at Equinix.
And that's a regional pair,
and then it's matched by a
pair across the country, and
there's that sort of
redundancy.
So that's hard to manage.
Sorry, the last piece I forgot
to mention with security is
there's often a flag.
I had a bizarre conversation
with the head of security at a
big backbone company who said
you can come visit our site,
please don't say where it is.
And if you enter the name of his
company and the town that
the landing station is in Maps,
a flag lands in the
middle of his desk.
So the implication that
these are somehow
secret is sort of bizarre.
Thanks to you guys.
AUDIENCE: Can you tell me a
little bit more about the
business relationships of owning
these buildings and
these lines that you discuss
so eloquently?
What does it mean that Google
now owns this building?
Are people paying us to house
the network connections?
Or are we paying into
some kind of fund?
How does that group that
you mentioned, the--
ANDREW BLUM: NANOG, yeah.
AUDIENCE: --network
administrators work?
ANDREW BLUM: Well, it's very
complicated, and it varies
building to building.
So take Ashburn, for example.
Equinix's business model is to
charge by the cross connect.
So you pay rent for your cage.
I forget, sometimes you do and
sometimes you don't pay power
to pay how much power
you need.
And then you pay for them to run
a cable across the room.
And that's the business model.
And it's all about
cross connects.
At NANOG, the biggest party at
NANOG is the Equinix party.
They want everyone to come and
drink beer and connect their
networks and buy
cross connects.
Telex, which also is in this
building, sometimes they say
no, we're just selling space,
we'll do the cross connect for
free, and that becomes a
kind of added value.
Then there's the other layer.
Ashburn's sort of a pure
example, because they own the
dirt, they own the building,
it's all Equinix.
This building is much more
complicated, because there is
a legacy history of the
different telecom companies
owning a suite of offices,
the different colocation
companies--
the kind of hotel equivalents,
like Equinix--
owning another piece of the
building, and then whoever
owns the building itself
allowing for the cables to run
between floors or
between offices.
At 60 Hudson, that code was
cracked first by Telex, sort
of Equinix's major competitors,
because they sort
of realized what the economic
value was--
the union labor required to
connect two floors, the amount
they had to charge one time or
two times or monthly, whatever
it was, for that connection--
but essentially, to cut
out the local loop.
To cut out the Bells or Verizon
or whoever it is where
you are, and allow two networks
to connect directly--
my router plugged into
your router.
The ecosystem of
this building--
and I'm on a little shaky ground
with this-- but the
basics are that if a Deutsche
Telekom or a Cablevision comes
in and has a suite of offices,
and the tradition has been
that they then can connect from
their suite to someone
else's suite, or if Equinix--
I think has 30,000 square feet
of space in this building--
can host a cage and everyone
can connect there.
Or if you're building a large
global data network for a
search engine, then the first
place you would go is to get a
suite of offices here, so you
can connect to everybody else.
To how the relationship is
between the landlord of this
building, the sublandlord of
an Equinix or a Telex or a
CoreSite, and then the existing
legacy communications
companies that have beachheads
here, and who allows them to
connect it--
if they have only do the
construction at night or
during the day and what the
limitations are on that--
is still figuring it out.
Certainly, if you're at Equinix,
and you're being told
you can no longer grow because
we need the building for the
office space, this is no
longer the most vibrant
meeting place of networks.
It becomes a very different
animal.
FEMALE SPEAKER: That's
all we have time for.
Sorry.
ANDREW BLUM: I'd be happy to
sign books, too, if you want.
FEMALE SPEAKER: FEMALE
SPEAKER: Books are
for sale for $10.
ANDREW BLUM: $10?
Oh, that's a really good deal.
[APPLAUSE]